-Enjoy yourself.
Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
Good to see you,
good to see you.
Good to see you again.
-Good to see you.
-Well, guys, everybody
is talking about this.
On Saturday,
former President Trump
held his first official
campaign rally in Texas.
Yeah, you could tell Trump was
nervous about getting arrested,
because he gave his speech
with one foot in Mexico.
[ Laughter ]
Along with Trump,
the crowd also heard
from Marjorie Taylor Greene,
Ted Nugent,
and the MyPillow guy.
[ Laughter ]
Rudy Giuliani was watching
at home like,
"Am I too crazy
or not crazy enough?"
Yep, Trump,
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
Ted Nugent,
and the MyPillow guy.
Or as they're also known,
Four Loko.
[ Laughter ]
That's the only group
where one person steps
out of the room
and the other three are like,
"Oh, boy."
Yep, Trump made
a lot of headlines
for his rally this weekend.
Well, I guess the staff tried
to keep him on message
by making him use
a teleprompter.
Check out what they were showing
to keep him focused.
-I gave them hundreds
and hundreds of javelins,
whereas Obama
gave them pillows.
We must not allow them to go
through another election
where they have
yet another tool.
We have some great congressmen
that probably
they wouldn't go after,
because they're too clean.
They're the cleanest people
I've ever met.
Our biggest threat
are high-level politicians
that work
in the United States government,
like Mitch McConnell,
Nancy Pelosi,
Schumer, Biden.
They've got nothing.
It probably makes me
the most innocent man
in the history
of our country.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Some -- Some business news.
Elon Musk just valued Twitter
at $20 billion,
which is less than half of
what he paid for it last year.
You got to give him credit,
though.
At a time when the price
of everything has gone up,
Elon cut Twitter in half.
So, I mean, that's --
he lost $24 billion in value.
Yeah it's strange
when "flammable Teslas"
aren't the worst thing
in your portfolio.
Hey, I saw that Dunkin' Donuts
just launched
their first-ever
breakfast tacos.
Yeah, and if you order that
with a coffee,
it's like adding Mentos
to Diet Coke.
[ Laughter ]
Pshhhh!
[ Fart ]
[ Applause ]
Yeah, Dunkin' said their goal
is to ruin tacos
the same way
they ruined avocado toast.
Oh, listen to this.
I read that Red Bull sales
are up, thanks to the return
of parties, exercise,
and people working
in the office.
It's weird.
It's like we're finally
healthy enough
to be unhealthy again.
Of course,
Red Bull gives you wings,
which is why today
Spirit Airlines
was pouring it
all over their planes.
[ Laughter ]
"I think I see someone --
One's sprouting, yes."
Some more business news.
Apple just released
a new shaking-face emoji.
Here it is.
[ Laughter ]
It's like someone who ate
a Dunkin' Donuts taco
and washed it down
with a Red Bull.
Guys, switching gears.
Not many people saw this coming.
The teams
in this year's Final Four
are Miami, Florida Atlantic,
UConn, and San Diego State.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Really?
The only way your brackets
got those four teams,
if you filled it out
this morning.
Let's be honest.
I'll be honest.
I think two of those teams might
just be online universities.
[ Laughter ]
CBS was like, "Just to
keep people interested,
Do you guys mind wearing
these jerseys that say
'Duke' on the front,
just to..."
Well, et this.
A travel tour company
is offering a 56-day trip
across Europe
that is being billed as the
world's longest bus journey.
The world's longest bus journey.
It's not great when
your main selling point sounds
like it was ripped
from a one-star review.
"World's longest bus journey."
[ Laughter ]
Do you guys know this?
Apparently,
today is National Viagra Day.
-Ooh!
[ Dramatic chord plays ]
-It's okay if you
didn't remember.
It always just kind of pops up
without warning.
-Hey! Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Finally, it is Monday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go, everybody.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you
a series of different tweets,
and we're all going
to vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want to do.
We'll see the results live,
on the screen here.
Higgins, Roots,
you have your clickers?
-Got it.
-Alright, good.
Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we're going to tweet it out
live on the show
so that you can all like it
and WeTweet it.
[ Crowd cheers ]
It's a shared experience.
Alright, you guys
ready for this?
[ Crowd cheers ]
First tweet is,
"What is it about
grocery-store free samples
that makes me so excited
about half a tortilla chip
in a paper cup?"
Like, "Ooh!
Ah, that's saying...
Mmm!
I like that.
I'll take a bag of those.
That's fantastic.
Half a chip?
I couldn't do any more.
Perfect.
Love it."
Uh, the votes are in.
Let's see the results here.
Alright, half. 50/50.
Yeah, half.
Half the people liked it,
half the people
did not enjoy it.
-9-3.
-No. Yeah.
Alright, how about
this next one here?
It says, "Office chairs
come in two styles: 'basic'
and 'captain's chair
on the Starship Enterprise.'"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Feels like
the crowd voted already.
-They voted with their laughs.
-Yeah, I feel like they're all
just kind of voting,
like not even animated.
You can move your hands.
You can -- I don't want you
to get up and dance,
but, yeah, you can do something.
-Yeah.
♪♪
Yeah, here we go. Yeah, alright.
Good, people dancing
to the music there.
I still say this is
probably 50/50 again.
Yeah, I think so.
-Now, let's see
the results in this one.
Alright, a little bit better.
Alright.
♪♪
A little reminder -- they
don't necessarily get better.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, next one says,
"The circle of life
is beautiful.
We cut down trees to make paper,
and then the paper
cuts us back."
[ Laughter ]
It's a beautiful thing.
Yeah, look at that.
-Come on!
-That's what I'm talking about.
It's a party tonight.
Alright, let's see
the results here.
What do we think?
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
Whoa!
-Wow!
-Hard to top.
134.
That's pretty hard to top.
I think it might be the one,
but let's check
this one out here.
Next up, "Ferris wheels
are the most romantic way
to slowly feel terrified."
[ Laughter ]
-"I'm not scared,
I'm not scared."
-"Not scared, not scared."
People are dancing.
[ Laughter ]
I love that. Alright, good.
Let's see the results here.
This one feels pretty good.
No, alright.
Feels good, but just
not as good as the other one.
-Wow.
-Yeah, I think
it's gonna be the other one.
Let's see. We have one more.
Last one here.
This one's pretty good.
-Okay?
-Really?
I'm ready for it.
-What was the other one?
What was the other one
that we all liked?
-Paper cut.
-Circle of life.
-I don't know if this one's
going to top paper cuts.
-Really?
-This one's pretty good, though,
but paper cuts is pretty --
-Yeah. Come on.
Alright, here we go. Last one.
"There are two types
of people in this world:
The ones who stop at
the blinking 'Don't walk' hand,
and the other ones who scream.
'Let's make this!'"
♪♪
[ Crowd cheers ]
Come on! We can do it!
♪♪
"Come on, get the kids!
Hold hands! Let's go!"
I feel good about this one.
-I feel good.
-I think this one
is going to top 174.
-I think so.
-You think so?
Let's see the results!
Yeah!
-Wow!
-Whoa!
That's a record! Record!
I love you guys!
That is our winner, right there!
199!
-Oh, my God!
-That is a record, right there.
I'm gonna post this right here
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like.
Give it a WeTweet and enjoy.